you've seen so many worlds you've seen
the music world growing up with your dad
you've seen basketball you know
advertising and now here in LA which is
a totally different ballgame mmm any
sense no pun intended by the way but
with it at the risk of sounding too like
cliche with this but talk about the dark
times and how you you can come out of
them because I'm sure you've seen a lot
whether it's just your own life from
other people and how do you maintain a
balance because this is a very very up
and down town it is up and down business
up and down town I think you get caught
up a lot here specifically in LA about
the approval of other people I think our
whole industry is built on approval of
others because you don't get paid if
other people don't like what you do and
so you're literally exposing yourself
every day to like hoping other people
like what you do and ultimately hope
they like you so that's dangerous I
think to a person's psyche to their
personality that's almost better we
lived somewhere else and didn't have to
deal with that but that's just the
reality of art right it's subjective and
you you are not going to be successful
if people do not give you their approval
and say oh I want to buy that record or
that painting or that sculpture or that
film whatever so that's the dangerous
part and that's when it gets dark is
when you don't have enough success to
support your you're not ego but just not
enough support to to feel good about
yourself and you start doubting your
your art or your passion or is this what
I'm supposed to be doing am I good
enough to do it maybe I shouldn't be
doing it and the funny thing is that's a
part of Buster moon you know there's a
part in the movie where he talks about
that and that's so real and so true and
it pertains to anybody who's ever moved
to LA to try and make music or try and
be an actress it can test your your will
it can test your dedication and a lot of
people give up and they don't make it I
don't have the answer on how to push
through it other than believe in
yourself and continue to try and improve
you know ever anybody told me that they
didn't like what I did I took it
personally and I really really would go
back to work and
I would sit in my studio at the time
which was in a bedroom and I would just
bang on my keyboard and make another
track and then turn it note and all I
couldn't do another one do another one
get better get better get better and I
would really take like a competitive
approach to it I was an athlete so
everything to me was like I have to beat
the next person so rather than start
doubting myself or questioning myself I
just I took people at their word I said
it's just probably not good enough let
me get better and I think that served me
well and I think I still try to do that
when I'm doing a project in the back of
my mind there's people I'm thinking
about that I want to do better than and
there's other people that I want to hear
this and some people I want them to be
mad because I did such a good job and
other people want them to be proud that
I did such a good job so that's
definitely a constant motivation for me
well you can even see in saying that
some of them have a few chips on their
shoulders and that that's not really a
bad thing we always hear that that's
such a negative thing but maybe it's
actually good to have it because it's a
driving force that if you don't you'll
get pummeled I don't know different
people have different ways of dealing
with it and coping with that some people
make music or make art just for
themselves and they're happy with that
like forget what everybody else says and
I'm just doing this because I love it
and that's one way of doing it I just
chose to be very competitive and I have
kids I want my kids to be proud I want
to leave a legacy after I'm done I want
people to think I did good work I want I
want to be able to lay down at the end
and be like yeah I'm happy with what I
did I'm happy with what I left behind I
think art is a really important part of
our culture in our society and if I can
create anything that lasts beyond my
life I think that would be great not to
get too philosophical but some of that
is my motivation it's not just about
sitting in a you know vacuum and making
music that pleases me I'm trying to do
things that I'm trying to do things that
might affect other people in a positive
way
you